中大膽周報
歡迎收看中大膽周報公開版 235 集
上個禮拜中大膽是不是有精準預言
大盤會往上攻可是遇到三萬四千點
可能就是一個關卡沒有辦法立刻 V 轉上去
我看到留言區有人說
請中總收下我的什麼膝蓋
就是非常佩服
那兆华呼吁一下
好多人在问中大胆周报什么时候上架
我们是固定礼拜天跟礼拜一的晚上6点钟
如果您怕错过的话
拜托拜托兆华的YouTube频道
订阅好不好
按下去啊
可能很多人都没有订都没有收到通知
订阅开启小铃铛就不会错过了
好当然我们这礼拜很精准
那我们还要再预言下一个礼拜
该如何是
哇这个每个礼拜都很伤脑筋
其实你不要讲说预测到下个礼拜
你光预测第二天的交易日
你就会觉得变化很大
尤其像上礼拜五
这个盘式马上之前强势的相关的PCB
马上在一天当中就变化很大
所以你还要预测到下个礼拜整周变化完
你就知道那要花很多的心思
我们上礼拜提到过
大陆3万4的时候你千万不要去做追
确实曾经有突破一下
但是也是瞬间
那这礼拜对台股的走势怎么看
坦白讲我个人认为会在这边做横盘的整理
那我们是不是先来看一下这一波的大盘指数
这波的大盘指数确实是有人在做控盘
怎么说呢你看最高点是35579点
然后最低是3月9号来到31529到32354那天
最低是31529
在这高低的位置当中高低差差了4050点
就是从高点到低档4050点
4054点的一半
大概就是2025点
也就是说如果这一半的话
落在哪个位置
落在33555左右
各位知道礼拜五的收盘多少
就是刚好就在中间
刚好就在月线附近
所以这个盘真的是有心能在做控盘
那这一步来讲
我们现在对低档位置
你说一定有能力说
那我们低档在
如果到31500点的时候
再来做买进
坦白讲你要到31500点
或32500以下
坦白讲现在难度会比较高了
不容易
真的吗
可是我看国际好动荡
感觉要再上
我觉得不太容易了
待会会再讲
各位投资人就应该很清楚
3万2以下是上市3月9号的时候
我们叫大家去买
如果你是公开看我们YouTube版的
你应该是这一波
少数能够买在最低档的位置去
真的
那这一波位置来讲
我大概认为了如果是3分11的修正大概就落落在32880也就是说如果指数这段时间大盘有波动的话来到32880
附近我觉得应该算是一个还不错的买点
那如果因为这波有来到三分之二位置处
大概落在34230
那最高来到34423
所以算是强势的跌升反弹
所以硬上如果图上所画的
就是这两条线会在这边附近整理
那下禮拜应该是多空重要的转折的一周
很重要的一周
那短线的支撑我还是维持在先前的看法
这在32,500点左右
那中期支撑是32,000
那328,800是极短线的部分
那我们再看周线图就很明显了
我上禮拜没有因为跌生反弹之后
我马上很不一转很开心
对没有
我还是会踩沙子
因为我们脑袋一直要维持一个很中性
那我想会不会是这一次第三次
掌握到波段的低点
到目前应该暂时是
这个3万2楼的部阱
我认为还是暂时是一个主要的位置点
我今天会来讲一个叫做
市场上担心的叫做外资的部分
外资的卖压影响
我个人认为会越来越小
会越来越来越小
三月外资卖了7000亿
超多了
应该是史上可能单月最大的卖超多
所以我为什么来说
因为大家都发现
现在外资率值在卖
我这觉得很奇怪
整天報紙或財經媒體說
每次外資都說看多麼當股票
奇怪外資一直都在賣
奇怪怎麼一直看多
到底是外資是偏多還偏空
我現在已經快也搞不清楚他們的想法
那原則上我覺得
我還是按照我們GDP
政府GDP的講法
來看台灣股市
我先問為什麼說外資的影響會越來越小是
首先來看這波大盤從3月份的高點拉回以來
外資大概就是你剛所講的
卖超了7000亿
但你可以发现
大盘还能够守在月线附近
过往如果卖7000亿
不知道跌到哪边去了
但是呢
既然能够守在这个位置
甚至在美一开战之后
那这个大盘还能够
有迅速的做一个拉起来
换句话说
我当时候算3万2
那一群人应该也可以算得出3万2
我都可以算得算
他们高手比我厉害
他们比我厉害
他们应该会算得出来
所以他们能够这样子算
我觉得外资卖亚影响性比较小
会越来越小
那为什么会越来越小
首先第一个是
目前外资的持股的所谓
我们去看
我有去对照过
比去年在四月份的时候
股债还来得低
因为它一路卖卖卖
差不多也都卖到一定相对
比当时低的水位
也就是说像外资卖的
都是在早期买的
去年到建民到今年现在为止
它不会早就卖光了
第二个是交易比重
这是非常重要
3月3号
3月4号
3月9号3月19号外資的單人賣超大概千億元就如我圖上所看那个看绿色柱状比较大的快接近千亿元它会造成股市大跌
但是呢
如果外资卖400亿
你就发现没什么感觉
那为什么
我分析给大家听
这边外面现在应该不太有论
会讲这块
我的想法有时候会蛮另类的
现在目前的交易量是8千亿
单日如果卖超400亿
这大概是什么
占交易量的差不多5%
那你要想一想
现在是8000亿
那你要想我们早期的时候
1500亿吧
算不算1500亿
1500亿的5%多少
75亿
如果1500亿卖75亿
你如果卖一支卖75亿
你会觉得怎么样
还好吗
因为以前外资卖百亿
你觉得就是大卖了
现在都四五百亿给你卖
对
如果以前75亿
你会觉得很恐怖吗
好现就不会那么恐怖
那现在的部位是8000亿
卖400亿占5%
那同樣你把它回想回去
1500億還是當時我以前叫大量
如果是用1000億
那只有什麼 50億
所以你說
如果1500億的水準量才賣75億
你就覺得好像沒那麼恐怖啊
那是如果1000億來算
那如果單日賣超過1000億的話
那大概就佔了12%
那我覺得是實質面跟心理面
會雙雙的影響
所以只要在400億
我大概這陣子觀察
400億左右的時候
外資賣的影響沒有那麼大
但如果到1000億或900億
就会有一些影响
因为有某种程度
第一个他占比重
我占一天的成交量
占了快进行12%
然后也1000亿大家看
好像有点恐怖
那另外一个就是
外资卖完之后
另外一定有一群人买
那另外一群人买
当然我们台面上看得到的
除了就是投信以外
但事实上你说投信
真的买很多吗
也没有很多
因为投信在3万2左右
你看3万
他们想法就跟我想法是一样
现在3万2附近
就要做买方
但是投信如果真的去看
它其实买也没很多
另外一个就是融资户
很多人会想融资好像大增
其实融资也没大增
像我最近看融资好像单日不到80亿
不过大概上市融资是4000亿左右
不会算再高吗
不会很高
我回头去看一下
目前单日的融资不到80亿
站台股交易量8000亿差不多1%
如果你换算以前1500亿1%
融资增加15亿
15亿增加很大吗
好像不很大
还好啊
那你就是当你的成交量增加了将近有
这个那么多从1500到8000
那相对也是从过去的15亿变成是叫做80亿
那也还好啊
所以你只要换个心在讲
15亿以前的融资你觉得多还不多
如果是不多那就不用紧张
融资的增加会占交易量大概1%
它有放大成数2.5倍左右
所以如果一天融资增加有这样的交易量的部分的话大概就是2.5%所以如果我剛才講的外資如果賣了1000億的話大概就是佔了5%左右
那外資賣5%
融資增加2.5%
那缺口呢
那當然就是會有另外一群人買
所以我這邊會來做一個總和的結論來講
為什麼外資大賣500億
你會發現台股賣還有限
如果外資賣超400到500億
占單天的交易量大5%
如果融资是增加70亿到80亿
占当天的交易量大概1%
那么大概就是2.5%
那加上投信光股建商
还有默默的在买的
受险这些等等的买差的话
那么大概它就是互相会
怎么会平衡
就不会有太大的卖压
所以呢台股当日卖压会有限
当然就要看当时的国际股市变化
但是相反的
如果融资也是卖的话
那就会比较大的卖压
我观察这段时间
融资会出现比较大的话
通常就是刚好外资也卖了快1000亿左右
才会有这样的情况
既然是如此的话
我想今天你听我这样解读之后
你就发现日后外资卖了四五百亿
你根本不用太紧张
因为卖了水位也卖了相对很低的
然后在家上有融资投信
还有这个关股建商
还有寿险资金都会进去做买超
所以还是秉持的
大跌你就大买
但是大涨你就千万不要追
因为你应该发现那天34000点的时候
投信就不去追了
政治小福调节
是
好我们其实看到这个网友们的回馈
订户们的回馈
我们最喜欢听到的就是
自从订阅了中大胆周报
甚至只有看公开版
都会觉得现在大涨大跌会出变不惊
现在也跟大家讲了
我们觉得外资卖很多
每次我跟总统说外资卖很多
他都会说其实真的没有那么严重
可是下去我们要勇敢减
上去也要知道
目前可能会有点反复的洗刷
所以选股的难度是增加的
而且现在中大展也会持续帮大家追踪股票喔
我们有看到留言区有人在问东洋到底怎么了
我们不会只讲涨的股票
东洋最近比较弱势
我们在我们的VIP订户里面
我们这一期就要来帮大家做追踪
我们非常的负责喔
涨的会帮您追踪
跌的一样帮您追踪
会不会反而是跌到甜甜价了呢
好有兴趣知道的朋友
欢迎订阅中大展周报
大家可以到电脑版首页赵华的头像旁边有一个加入的按钮
或是你随便选一集VIP的订阅影片
你点进去他都会有教您怎么做订阅哦
那手机订阅的朋友我也会把订阅连结放在留言的第一则
记得哦如果是手机是苹果的可能会多加附加费用
建议尽量用电脑版来订号
手机电脑是同一个账号就都可以看
不要担心我们VIP见咯
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive